في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه القوات الأوكرانية لشن
هجوم مضاد جديد هائل ، أصبح
لديها الآن سلاح فتاك جديد في
أرسنال ، أفادت CNN حصريًا
أن بريطانيا قد سلمت إلى
أوكرانيا صواريخ كروز Advanced Storm Shadow الخاصة بها
نوعًا من القدرة بعيدة المدى
لطالما كانت كييف تتوسل.  من أجل
التبرع بأنظمة الأسلحة هذه يمنح
أوكرانيا أفضل فرصة للدفاع عن
نفسها ضد الوحشية الروسية المستمرة ،
يمنح Storm Shadow
القوات الأوكرانية القدرة على الضرب
بعمق خلف الخطوط الروسية
وصفها مسؤول غربي بأنها
رد متناسب على استهداف روسيا
للبنية التحتية المدنية لكن
القوات الأوكرانية  تعهدت بإطلاق
الصواريخ فقط داخل
الأراضي الأوكرانية ذات السيادة بعدم مهاجمة روسيا
نفسها بينما رفضت الولايات المتحدة حتى الآن
تزويد أوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيدة المدى
مثل الهجمات خوفًا
من إثارة انتقام روسي ، كانت المملكة المتحدة
أكثر ميلًا إلى الأمام
إمدادات الأسلحة الخاصة بها في الأشهر الأخيرة ،
قدمت المملكة المتحدة دبابات ويسترن تشالنجر 2 الحديثة
قبل أن تقرر الولايات المتحدة تزويد
دبابات أبرامز الخاصة بها. The Storm Shadow هو
صاروخ كروز يتم إطلاقه عادةً من
الجو بقدرات تخفي يبلغ
مداه أكثر من 155 ميلًا ثلاث
مرات  مدى الصواريخ التي قدمتها الولايات المتحدة ، فإن
قدرات العاصفة Shadow
مكملة حقًا لما
يخطط له الأوكرانيون في
هجوم الربيع ، فهو قادر على استخدام
صور الفيديو لاستهداف المناطق الفعلية التي
يسعون إليها بعد أن
قال وزير الخارجية الأمريكية ذلك  أوكرانيا
لديها بالفعل ما تحتاجه لتكون
ناجحة ، تقديري الخاص هو أنها
وضعت في مكانها عبر كل تلك
الأبعاد ما يحتاجون إليه لمواصلة
النجاح في استعادة الأراضي
التي استولت عليها بالقوة من قبل روسيا خلال
الأشهر الـ 14 الماضية الرئيس الأوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي  من ناحية أخرى ،
قال إن بلاده ليست مستعدة تمامًا ،
قائلاً إنه لا يزال ينتظر المساعدة التي
وعدت بها بالفعل ، متوقعًا
وصول المركبات المدرعة على دفعات ، يمكننا
التقدم بما لدينا وأعتقد أننا
يمكن أن نكون ناجحين ولكننا سنخسر
الكثير  من الأشخاص الذين أعتقد أن هذا
غير مقبول ، نحتاج إلى الانتظار وقد
قال المسؤولون البريطانيون مرارًا وتكرارًا إنهم
يعتبرون شبه جزيرة القرم ذات السيادة الأوكرانية
أيضًا والتي من شأنها أن تضع بعضًا
من أغلى ممتلكات روسيا العسكرية
بما في ذلك أسطولها في البحر الأسود
والمخاطر المحتملة من هذا
السلاح الجديد عالي القدرة  نظام
جيم شودو سي إن إن واشنطن ،
الإعلان عما
قاله لي مسؤول عسكري أمريكي كبير هو
تغيير كبير في قواعد اللعبة عندما يتعلق الأمر بالأسلحة
لأوكرانيا في الحرب مع روسيا ،
أكدت المملكة المتحدة أنها سلمت
صواريخ ستورم شادو طويلة المدى لأوكرانيا.
ليس معروفًا أنه
صاروخ كروز يتم إطلاقه عادةً من الجو وله مدى يبلغ
ثلاثة أضعاف مدى الصواريخ التي
توفرها أوكرانيا
حاليًا كما تم توفيره من قبل الولايات المتحدة.
لذا فإن
نطاق الأسلحة الحالي للقوات الأوكرانية
قدمته الولايات المتحدة 49 ميلًا ، وهذا أمر
مقصود سنتحدث عنه في
لحظة أه أحدثها ، ستورم
شادو هنا ، المدى يصل بك إلى حوالي
155 ميلاً ، ما هو الفرق الذي
يحدثه ذلك؟  بالنسبة للأوكرانيين ، فإن
الاختلاف الذي يجعل جيم هو
حقًا عميق جدًا لأنه يتعلق
بثلاثة أضعاف مسافة الأسلحة
التي تمتلكها أوكرانيا حاليًا ، هذه هي
نسخة التصدير من Storm Shadow ،
نسخة فرنسا وبريطانيا التي تستخدمها ، لدي
بالفعل ضعف  ضاعف هذا النطاق
أيضًا ، لذا فإن ما تتحدث عنه هو
صاروخ كروز بقدرات التخفي
ولديه أيضًا قيلولة من
قدرة الملاحة الأرضية مما يعني
أنه يطير على ارتفاع 150 مترًا فوق
الأرض أو أقل بقليل من
ذلك.  صاروخ مهم للغاية من
هذا المنصة يمكن أن يسمح لهم
بالخداع تحت نظام الدفاع الصاروخي الروسي وقد
رأيت هذه الطائرات تحلق في أوكرانيا
وبالمناسبة من المخيف رؤية
أحدهم لأنهم لا يطيرون بهذه السرعة
يمكنك فعلاً  أراهم وهم
يتنقلون ، وهو على أي حال
تهديد إذا رأيت أحدهم يقترب ،
فلنلقِ نظرة على خريطة أوكرانيا
لأن المسافة هي المفتاح هنا الآن في
تقريري عن الاتفاقية بين
المملكة المتحدة وأوكرانيا للحصول على هذه الأسلحة
التي لديهم  كنت تتوسل منذ
فترة طويلة من الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
أنهم لن يطلقوا النار إلا داخل
الأراضي ذات السيادة الأوكرانية
التي احتل بعضها بالطبع من قبل روسيا
وليس إطلاق النار على روسيا ، لذلك دعونا نتحدث عن
النطاق هنا لأن هذا النطاق له
150  دعونا نتحدث عن الأميال لنقل
المسافة بين قل zaparita و
kershawan هنا تقريبًا مشابهة لتلك
المسافة حتى تتمكن من إطلاق النار على سبيل المثال
من هنا إلى شبه جزيرة القرم ، وهذا صحيح ،
فهذه مشكلة بالنسبة لروسيا والشيء الرئيسي
هو أن جيم تعترف
المملكة المتحدة بشبه جزيرة القرم.  الأراضي الأوكرانية ذات السيادة
ونتيجة لذلك ،
يكون من المنطقي تمامًا أن يتم
توفير سلاح به هذا النطاق ، وهذا أمر
مهم لأنه ليس هنا فقط
وبالمناسبة نطاق سهل مع هذا لإطلاق النار
على سبيل المثال في دونيتسك لوهانسك في
المنطقة الشرقية  المقاطعات أه حاليًا
أيضًا المناطق الحمراء هنا التي تحتلها
القوات الروسية ، والمشكلة بالنسبة لنا
سأغير اللون مرة أخرى فقط
حتى يسهل على الناس رؤيتها أنه
مع هذا النطاق يمكنك
إطلاق النار عبر الحدود إلى روسيا و
هذا ما أثار قلق المسؤولين الأمريكيين ،
يجب أن أذكره مرة أخرى على الرغم من أن الأوكرانيين
قالوا إنهم لن يفعلوا ذلك بسبب
قلق المسؤولين الأمريكيين ، لذا فإن ما يريدون
فعله هو التأكد من عدم وجود أي
أرض روسية في نطاق أي
نظام أسلحة أوكراني والسبب.
لأنك تفعل ذلك لأنه على سبيل
المثال هنا هو بيلجارود
وهي منطقة بها أسلحة نووية
ولديها أيضًا قاعدة عسكرية روسية
وهي قريبة جدًا من الحدود الأوكرانية
حيث سيكون هناك نطاق سهل حتى
من السلاح  الأنظمة التي
تمتلكها أوكرانيا حاليًا لذلك يريدون التأكد من
أن الأوكرانيين يفيون بهذا
الوعد حتى لا يرفعوا
التوترات ويجلبوا الروس إلى
مستوى أعلى من القتال ونحن نعلم على سبيل
المثال أن الأوكرانيين كانوا
يطلبون ذلك  هذا هو
نظام الصواريخ الأمريكي بعيد المدى المعروف باسم
الهجمات بناءً على أه استنادًا إلى
اختصاره هناك 185 ميلًا
أطول قليلاً ، لقد أرادوا هذا بدلاً من ذلك ، فهم
يحصلون على فرق كبير في Storm Shadow
هناك للقوات الأوكرانية لذلك
هناك بعض الاختلاف في أن هذا في الواقع
له نطاق أطول قليلاً مما
يوفره Storm Shadow ولكن
الاختلاف الكبير في الواقع هو أن Storm
Shadow لديه بعض القدرات التي
لا يمتلكها atacums
وتتضمن هذه القدرات خريطة GPS
لإمكانية التنقل في الأرض
والسبب  من أجل ذلك أه ، يسمح في الواقع
باستخدام أكثر كفاءة لقوة النار
واستهدافًا أكثر فاعلية مثيرًا للاهتمام ،
لذا فإن نطاقًا أقل قليلاً من القدرات
ومرة ​​أخرى قبل أن نذهب فقط للإشارة إلى
القوات الأوكرانية التي تستعد لهجوم
مضاد في الوقت الحالي ونظام الأسلحة الجديد هذا
هذا النظام الصاروخي الجديد
سيمنحهم قدرات
لم تكن لديهم من قبل سيدريك لايتون ، شكرًا جزيلاً
لبريانا دائمًا